what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into this story one of
the questions that I've been seeing is
because the entity of the Black Lantern
Corps is a being named Necron one of the
things people ask is is necron the same
as like the other entities like parallax
and so on and so forth the more I sort
of thinking about that the more that got
me thinking well why not create an
explanation on the emotional spectrum
now we are going to talk about what
happens in this video but this video
centers on Superman becoming the host
for parallax but what I want to do is I
want to throw in the emotional spectrum
explanation of this we're actually gonna
put it in with the videos that we have
in our playlist on green lantern that
way you guys who are just kind of
jumping into the playlist will get an
explanation of the emotional spectrum as
well as you know this cool little story
that takes place in DC Comics so the
emotional spectrum is one of the oldest
things in existence right like it's a
span of emotions is basically the core
emotions that every sentient being feels
and the idea here is that the emotional
spectrum consists of rage and greed and
fear and willpower and hope and
compassion love death life it's this
idea that it basically encompasses
everything that makes up being who they
are now the idea is it again every
sentient being across the universe feels
emotions and those emotions funneled
directly into the emotional spectrum
itself so as time progresses and as
another of those emotions begin to grow
is the sentience of the universe
increases those emotions begin to come
together and they begin to coalesce in
sorts and so what this means is that in
each part of the emotional spectrum
there is an entity that represents that
spectrum in this instance in this story
is the entity of parallax now parallax
is literally the living embodiment of
fear but the idea here is that that with
the parallax concept he's waxed and
waned over the years when it came to the
Green Lantern mythos in terms of how
it's been adjusted over the years was
just to say the changes that have been
made and how it stands in the modern day
how Jordan took off into space he was on
a mission he came back fanned out Coast
City had been destroyed by cyborg
superman and this left him open and so
he was possessed by the parallax entity
and then started calling himself
parallax and then went on a crusade
killed all the Green Lantern's yadda
yadda yadda but what we're gonna see on
Sundays in our Green Lantern videos is
we'll see that these entities will start
popping up the red lantern entity is the
butcher for example the whale is the
representation of willpower in the DC
Universe
one of these entities is basically in
amalgamation of that power I wanted to
throw that out there because I wanted to
make sure people understood how the
emotional spectrum works again it's
basically just this idea that's so long
as there are beings in the universe that
will feel fear that will feel rage and
compassion and you know love and all the
different emotions that we ran over
earlier then the emotional spectrum will
exist now having said that when it comes
to this particular story the cool thing
is that what this does is it initially
just picks up with a young kid and this
kids just kind of you know going through
and exploring and actually looking at
the future home for the LexCorp gardens
which basically looks like it was a
former school at one point and it's been
torn down ever since but what this
initially does is it basically comes to
us and shows us that a lot of these kids
around this town have basically gone
missing now again this is a cool thing
about Superman rebirth
and this is what I love about Superman
rebirth so much is it takes Superman
back to his roots
in DC Comics when it came to the new 52
a lot of emphasis was put on that
version of Superman being the one who
deals with like these huge conflicts and
things like that you got stories where
he dealt with small things but by and
large it was just one major event after
another and the result is that we didn't
get a whole lot of instances where we
got these points to see Superman dealing
with the small guys but this reborn
Superman this classic Superman basically
in DC rebirth this is the one that we're
most familiar with this is the one who's
just as likely to deal with you know
some massive planet-wide calamity as he
is to like help a lady cross the street
they're equally as important to him and
so in this instance parents showing up
and saying our kids are missing it's
Superman basically come along and saying
fine then we'll help you guys find out
you know I'm Superman I'm here to
protect everybody large and small I will
do the best I can to help try to track
down your kids and see what's going on
now of course what we end up finding out
is that the reason why these kids are
vanishing is because these kids one of
them anyway is being possessed by the
parallax entity and what is up happening
is that where Superman basically tracks
this kid down where he realizes that it
seems to be parallax but isn't a hundred
percent sure this kid starts talking
about things like fear I know what
you're afraid of you know this and this
and that and that now that's what makes
parallax so dangerous is because
remember people don't willingly feed
parallax it's not like Superman can sit
down and say all man dude I'm scared man
I better not feel fear otherwise I could
make parallax stronger but parallax
being the living embodiment of fear
knows what everyone is afraid of and
that's what makes him so dangerous is
because with enough fear if you're
afraid
enough things if he shows you enough of
your worst nightmares then if your
willpower is not strong enough like the
Green Lantern's then ultimately you'll
end up falling prey to the nature of
parallax himself and so that's what ends
up happening is Superman is possessed by
parallax and that's why this is so crazy
is because he doesn't immediately know
it now the reason why this matters is
because this is how it was with Hal
Jordan when Hal Jordan first became
parallax it wasn't like a sudden you
know shift it was a gradual thing it was
one day he woke up and realized that he
was he with he had gray hair he had a
gray steel gray stripes on the side of
his head you know he would just have
this feeling of discontent he would feel
like something's not right it was an
itch that he couldn't scratch he
couldn't really figure it out but in
this instance where Superman is
possessed by parallax it literally takes
hold of him and its entirety now
remember this is classic Superman so
it's not like he's unfamiliar he knows
exactly who parallax is and Superman
knows exactly how dangerous parallax is
now with Superman basically being taken
over by the parallax entity once he's a
host to it it immediately conquers him
and the reason for this is because
Superman is not like Hal Jordan
Superman's strong Superman is capable
he's got a lot to live for but it would
be like me coming to you and saying hey
here's schematics for like a skyscraper
that I want you to build now build it
you would have no idea you wouldn't know
how to code you would be inexperienced
with it and that's how it is with
Superman the reason why Superman doesn't
wield a Green Lantern ring is because
most likely he may not have the
willpower to be able to do it because
what you're talking about doing is
keeping fear at bay 100% of the time
when it comes to Hal Jordan it's
basically just him he's got friends he
doesn't have any kids he doesn't have a
family or anything like that Superman
has a wife he's got a son he's looking
to the future
he's looking to return to what he
believes himself to be the superhero of
Metropolis as he remembered being from
his classic DC Universe so because of
all this it's this idea that when he's
taken over by the parallax entity it
makes sense because it's far easier to
instill fear in Superman than it is in
Hal Jordan because Superman has a lot
more to lose than Hal Jordan now of
course what this does is with Superman
becoming parallax he's immediately met
by the arrival of Sinestro now this is
one of the reasons why I wanted to do
the fractured story from Green Lantern
Corps those are guys who don't who
didn't get a chance to see that video
fractured wasn't the most important
story I mean it basically dealt with the
aftermath of the death of Sinestro
during the first story arc of Hal Jordan
the Green Lantern Corps rebirth what we
ended up finding out is that from the
time that we saw Hal Jordan in the Green
Lantern Corps with Sinestro's law all
the way up until the fractured story and
Sinestro was gone
we had his Lantern Corps working
alongside the Green Lantern's now of
course there was a rift hence the reason
why the story was called fractured they
ended up going their own separate ways
but at the end of the fractured story we
basically found out that Sinestro was
alive now Sinestro and parallax go hand
in hand they are they they are like peas
and carrots they are two peas in a pod
and it works because we're parallax goes
Sinestro goes the other half of this
equation comes in the form of parallax
himself just because parallax is the
living embodiment of fear does not mean
the parallax controls fear parallax
simply just knows what people are afraid
of now parallax can manipulate you know
the element of fear but parallax is
simply just an entity he's a harbinger
of fear itself and so when Sinestro and
the yellow lanterns tap into the
emotional spectrum they're half tapping
into the power of parallax by extension
of the fact that they're tapping into
fear the reason why this matters is
because there came a point when parallax
was actually enslaved by Sinestro and
use as essentially a battery source for
the Sinestro Corps itself and that's why
this is so important is because this is
not necessarily a battle between
Sinestro and Superman this is a battle
between parallax and Sinestro
it's basically parallax simply arguing
you are not going to enslave me again
now for Sinestro parallax is really the
only way he can go back to the way he
used to be it allowed him to reach the
height of his power when it came to the
Sinestro Corps if you were to simply
back off any word of just going back to
tapping into the emotional spectrum
there's probably no way he'd be able to
defeat Hal Jordan just because right now
in the stories Hal Jordan is willpower
itself and so in this instance what this
does is it creates a showdown of sorts
in the sense did we get this really
really cool moment where Sinestro is
able to basically overcome parallax as
he possesses Superman using the
weaponers of cord now of course the
weaponers of cord come from the
antimatter universe they are a huge part
of the Green Lantern mythos and they've
been around ever since Sinestro was
first introduced in DC Comics way back
in like the 1950s or 1960s and the
is the weaponers were the ones who
actually created the Sinestro Corps
rings for Sinestro himself but they're
more of a group who were viewed to be
warriors but has since been turned into
what what amounts to slaves more or less
for Sinestro but the cool thing is that
looking at Superman and using his power
Sinestro begins to look at what
terrifies Superman so much and this is
why I give this video the title will
Superboy kill Superman because when it
comes to things like this
DC uses these scenarios to basically
give us a glimpse at future stories to
say here is the direction things are
going to be going in later on down the
line or a potential future for
particular character and in fact we know
there's going to be a story coming out
in December or at least video of our
comic story and pointed it out to me
there's a story coming out in December
where it's basically going to be
Superman traveling to the future to try
to stop Superboy from becoming a bad guy
the theory that comics Taurean has and
the theory that I agree with is that the
son of Superman will become
superboy-prime because in this scenario
in this glimpse into the fear that
Superman has he's literally killed by
his son he's murdered by his own son and
that begs the question will that happen
but again it's DC basically saying hey
guys like here's a glimpse of a story
that you might see you later on down the
line you probably will see Superman
fighting his own son and his son killing
him so that's why these things are kind
of cool but more so than that this is
one of the biggest fears that Superman
has because remember when it came to him
and his character when it came to
Superman and it came to the idea of his
son developing powers the goal was to
basically nurture the abilities of his
son and nurture the upbringing of his
son in such a way that when the time
came when his powers began to manifest
and when he was at this crossroads where
he knew what he was capable of and he
was choosing the road of being a good
guy or being a bad guy without question
he would choose the road of a good guy
and eventually become a hero just like
his father
the fear of Superman is that there will
be hesitation the fear of Superman is
that there will be a moment of weakness
and in that moment of weakness his son
will kill all the superheroes the flash
Batman so on and so forth and then turn
around and kill Superman it shows us
what Superman fears the most
failing letting people down not being
there save somebody in the nick of time
that's the core of Superman Superman is
a good guy in every ounce of the word
does everything he can the problem with
this is that parallax because it's
trying to escape
Superman starts jumping ship jump
one host body to the nether to Lysa Drac
who's basically this woman is kind of
like the chronicler of the Sinestro
Corps it starts jumping from body to
body the different weaponers of court
taking possession of them and every step
along the way Sinestro is chasing after
it and that's why this is so cool
because what does it say when the living
embodiment of fear is terrified of
someone that shows us just how capable
and evil Sinestro really is but at the
moment the goal of Sinestro is basically
in you know to attempt to try to take
down parallax to reacquire him and
reaching this peak level of power of
course Superman is able to jump into the
way after making his escape and then in
turn takes the ring off Sinestro and
actually imprisons parallax inside of it
and then takes the ring with him when it
comes to parallax because of the fact
that parallax is a living embodiment of
fear the fear emotional spectrum still
exists it's still there and Sinestro's
forces will still be able to tap into it
but what it does do is it takes away the
ability for Sinestro to be as powerful
as he was before they basically just
kind of reduce his power and so because
of that Superman reaches out to these
weaponers and that again is the other
half of why Superman is so cool a
Superman is a living embodiment of hope
Superman is a person that basically
implements this idea that people will
always look to the brighter future and
in that hope the possibility exists that
their life can get better and that's
what he says to the weaponers of course
is look you guys have been made to feel
fear by Sinestro you guys were literally
enslaved but I hear that you guys are
warriors I hear that you guys are proud
and capable warriors and so my biggest
question is this why are you serving
Sinestro leaved form your own role
become your own heroes choose what
direction your life will go in from this
day forward and so again what this seems
to do is basically start closing off all
these doors - Sinestro his ability to
restore to 100% absolute power as
possessing the parallax entity is now
gone because it's in the ring that's
held by Superman the ability for the
weaponers of court to basically serve as
these guys that gives Sinestro
everything he needs is essentially a
beginning to go away as this begins to
wrap up what it does is it actually has
Superman taking this moment to watch his
son sleep and the reason why is because
we look at Superboy right now in DC
rebirth and we say this is a kid who's
young he's vibrant he's learning his
powers but then we asked
question but what if what Superman
solves biggest fear comes true what if
it comes to a point where the Superboy
looks around and says you were never
there as a dad you are off fighting
alongside Batman and you were just out
saving the day all the time
and I was just left to kind of raise
myself or go with mom doing the best she
could you were basically an absentee dad
and in that anger in that rage Superboy
becomes a bad guy so again that's why
this is so cool is because it gives us
this possibility that not all that
glitters is gold that maybe just maybe
as unlikely as it may seem as impossible
as it may seem that perhaps there's a
possibility out there that Superboy the
son of Superman will become a villain
and will kill his father but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain and make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]